Saudi Arabian Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman will meet Tuesday with President
Trump at the White House the meeting
will be the third face-to-face encounter
for the two leaders President Trump
visited the kingdom for his first
foreign trip last May he was accompanied
by his senior adviser and son-in-law
Jared Kushner in an interview for Sunday
60 minutes we asked the 32 year old
Crown Prince about that visit Kushner
and the president plan to move the US
Embassy in Israel to Jerusalem the White
House chose Saudi Arabia for president
Trump's first visit as president and you
rolled out the red carpet for him what's
your relationship like with President
Trump placement President Trump is the
elected US president and the Saudi
American relations are historic going
back nearly 80 years
phenoix pasa in fact Saudi Arabia is the
oldest ally to the u.s. in the Middle
East before any other country one of the
things that President Trump has talked
about is Middle East peace
he has his son-in-law Jared Kushner
working on that that's part of his
portfolio I know that you've met with
him have you discussed Middle East peace
with him that's right Jared is assigned
this portfolio by the White House
our duty as Saudis is to improve
relations with our allies and with all
representatives of these institutions
does president Trump's decision to move
the American Embassy to Jerusalem help
or hurt the peace process and then how
would we try to focus on the efforts
that promotes peace for all we do not
try to focus on anything that might
create tension it is my nature always to
be positive that many jabya so I try to
focus on the things that will support
the interests of the Palestinian people
and the interests of all there's no
doubt this has been an incredibly close
relationship remember when President
Trump went there along with Jared
Kushner they announced a 100 billion
dollar arms deal that has yet to fully
materialized but and of course the US
has supported Saudi Arabia's efforts in
Yemen and he speaks English but he chose
not to speak English in the interview
with him yeah I mean especially when
talking about Paul
see he wants to speak in his native
tongue he does speak English but it's I
think he's more comfortable in Arabic
yeah and that visit to Saudi Arabia was
about a US policy that was going to be
realistic about the Middle East join
with the Saudis against the Iranians and
just just kind of move in a totally new
direction so Saudi Arabia is the sort of
Avenue through which US policy is going
to change right and he's not only
visiting with President Trump on Tuesday
he's going to be here for several weeks
as they seek more foreign investment in
Saudi Arabia and also because there's a
thought that what happens in Saudi
Arabia's can certainly affect the entire
Middle East they were talking about this
interview in Saudi Arabia Jon yesterday
Nora and I were doing a shoot about
women who anchored the news with John
Dickerson and a guy who was in the in
the dining room said hey Nora
he's from Saudi Arabia we can't wait to
see your interview they are talking
about it in both places we all can't
wait yes and you can see our full report
with the Crown Prince Sunday night on 60
minutes it airs at 7 6 central right
here on CBS